hurry jack nation we're back at it again
yeah it's three to three and no one's
winning John and I take a shot before
every single one of these videos to
celebrate the Super Bowl by the time we
get to the last trailer we're gonna be
trashed
it's Mission Possible time baby's gonna
be all slop you'll see like reasonable
energy Jurassic world a little higher
energy with solo but now it's its peak I
can't wait to watch Dwayne Johnson judge
that building we're gonna be here when
everyone else is having a party it might
as well bring the party to hear you and
you and you you know reaction let's
watch hey shots a reaction to time let's
watch skyscraper
[Music]
[Music]
as a rod cliffhanger is his prosthetic
leg going it's weird as this this is a
rock movie right here this is the rock
no no no but he's got a prosthetic leg
so he's no no no he's not as much of the
rock as he typically is I feel like
heard this will hinder him a lot I feel
like every other trailer except for
Jumanji I'm like I've seen the rock do
this role right so you can be this guy
before happen yeah the last time it was
just a really big earthquake what's
weird is the director of rampage san
andreas i thought the director sandra's
would have done this this is actually
director of Central Intelligence right
here and dodge ball what a weird what a
weird movie for this director because
this is like a more serious film hey
break out the mold if you want I didn't
know the rock believes in him John and I
did like a quick Wikipedia search on
this movie to like what the hell is
skyscrapers looking at it's a disaster
they said disaster from something like a
disaster film this looks like die hard
but sky crazier yeah yeah he's trapped
he has to go rescue them at the top it's
die hard but more the bigger I think
yeah I don't know it gave me vibes of
like die hard I thought I was gonna
become like the raid at some point I
thought I was gonna become like the
towering inferno at some point I don't
know is just the rock gonna fight his
way to the top of this giant skyscraper
- I don't know what here's what I liked
about it that actually genuinely
surprised me about this trailer usually
when the rock is serious I don't really
believe him or buy him I love him in a
good in a comedy like Central
Intelligence or Jumanji you know all the
countless comedies The Rock has done
into action comedies I really do like
him and 7 dress is fun and whatever and
rampage looks cool but this role I was
watching I'm like you know I
believe him actually I think he's a more
confident serious actor now so seeing
him as this dad who really wants to
rescue his family but that is that is
the Dwayne Johnson it's the angel in
character that's strange bass kills the
rock is like a terrific charismatic yeah
also then has to go on an adventure like
and become a superhero to save them
I guess we're surprising about this is
this looks like really serious now with
all those positives being said I don't
know what looks so unique about this
film that everyone's so hyped about what
do you mean is another entry into give
to give me back my family nothing
different about charismatic incredibly
buff dudes killing a lot of people to
get their families I feel like I've seen
the rock play this for a bunch of times
and I feel like I've seen this movie
dress was about the disease a helicopter
he's a rescue helicopter pilot but he's
got a save his family at all costs
yeah The Rock's done this role playing
times in this movie doesn't look exactly
original it's just a 45 second spot no
it just it just looks like maybe it
could be another fun example of this
John but is it even gonna be fun though
John I don't know I feel like with
Dwayne Johnson there is certainly a
potential and especially because they
both work together on a comedy it's like
really serious each other we humor
implemented into this or how it could be
I don't know it looks like it could be
really ridiculous I imagine it'll
probably be more that San Andreas vibe
of why they're saying so it's really
serious and that's why I think it's fun
because it's so cheesy
what's going on well dude I mean you're
setting yourself up for perfect triple
feature of skyscraper high-rise and room
alright guys well what do you think of
the skyscraper turret what do you think
of our first look at this are you more
excited for this in Jurassic world then
rampage were you more except for this
then it's the solo movie what are you
excited about are you more excited for
this than Doritos bleh and Budweiser
all right we'll see you in a few minutes
subscribe you know the drill
there's buttons here do stuff